some people deceive themselves into
thinking they're further ahead than they
are you know they always want to tell
you how well they're doing and they're
sort of deceiving themselves and that
deception leads to lack of activity
drive desire you and i do the reverse
yeah i deceive myself i'm further behind
than i am i know you do this too because
we've talked about it i love deceiving
myself i love deceiving our company i
love deceiving the team malcolm x has
this great quote he says that which you
do not hate you will eventually tolerate
i'm a big believer i gotta almost
despise where i am right now and i do so
i'm kind of the king of deception with
myself
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
ed milette and my take on his top 10
rules for success enjoy
rule number two evaluate your story if
you're stuck
you're stuck in a story that's where
you're stuck there's a story you're
telling yourself that doesn't serve you
anymore
and you have to evaluate what that story
is i'm serious right now if you say ed
i'm kind of stuck where i am well what
you need to do is you need to alter your
associations you need to do something in
a short window of time no question about
it you definitely need to evaluate what
is no longer needed and evaluate the
story you're telling yourself there's
all kinds of stories we tell ourselves
that don't serve us anymore this is
critical maybe it's a story about your
past a story about your parents a story
about a previous relationship a story
about a success you used to have you
keep talking about that doesn't serve
you to get to the next level
if i can be real with you whatever
you've achieved up to this point that
story you keep talking about every
second you spend in that old story about
what you've achieved your degree
some business you had one thing you were
real successful at in the past every
time you live in that story you're
stripping time and focus from the news
story what's the new story you're
telling yourself you can't have a new
identity without a new story
what's the old story you keep for being
maybe it's not a success maybe it's a
failure that you've had it was a
business setback it was the market
turned it was the economy it was someone
who did you wrong a relationship that
let you down a business partner who
wasn't consistent a failure you've had a
poor decision you made
a mistake you made
in your life and you're repeating this
story to yourself
simultaneously trying to create a new
identity you can't take that old story
into the new identity rule number three
dream
big you got to be able to have a big
enough dream that the visions and the
dreams of the people you're going to
enroll into your organization they're
going to become a part of your team or
your company
their dreams and their visions can fit
inside this big one you've got that's
what makes you magnetic that's what
makes you compelling that's what
attracts people to you and so anything
art used to say any church boy scout
troop football team you show me some
that's when it's run by a leader and
leaders have a vision where there is no
vision people perish where there's no
vision your business perishes
where there's no dream whatever endeavor
it is you're involved in will eventually
perish but if the dreams alive the
dreams big enough you can accomplish
anything because you'll overcome the
adversity the tough times and difficult
times that the people who ultimately
lose won't overcome really winning in
business is more about staying power
more about relentlessness more about
tenacity more about vision more about
dreams than it's ever about skill you
show me something with enough vision a
big enough dream i'll show you somebody
who will eventually acquire the skills
the talents or the other people
necessary to make that huge dream happen
but i've seen all kinds of talented
people all kinds of skilled people
that succumb to adversity to the
difficult times to the lows rule number
four avoid your phone in the morning
most of you lose control of your life in
the first five minutes after you wake up
i talk about it in my book and you begin
to respond all day long the first thing
is this the hardest thing you will do
and the thing that will change your life
almost with the greatest impact is to
not check your phone for the first 30
minutes you wake up in the morning i'm
telling you that it might be the biggest
game changer it is the biggest game
changer for me it was so difficult
because so what i did is i i moved it
away from where i sleep but i'm just
going to say to you all you think that's
not a big deal i got to check it i'm
telling you if you could go 30 minutes
if you could start by going 10 minutes
to begin your day something where you do
not check that sucker and react and then
what you say about the gratitude thing
that's profound for me and it's a
breakthrough for me when you said it i'm
always kind of what are the big things
i'm great i'm grateful for god i'm
grateful for my kids you reduce it down
to just something what's the smallest
thing you could be grateful for right i
love that because there's always a small
thing you'd be grateful for you know i'm
grateful my i clipped my toenails
yesterday whatever it is right there's
something so i just want to validate how
powerful i think both those simple tools
the simplest things make the biggest
impacts in our lives
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five bounce back you and i
watched with every successful person
that we know everyone gets hammered man
everyone gets knocked down you get a you
miss a close someone changes their mind
yeah you get rejected in an interview
you you
you lose your baseball card whatever the
hell it is it's not whether you're
getting knocked down it's not even
whether you'll get up everybody
eventually gets up everybody gets up
yeah it's the time you're on your ass
it's the time you stay on the mat so
what happened was my dream got squashed
instead of laying around for six or
eight months i was up immediately like
that day off the mat now my eyes are
open your eyes are closed when you're on
the mat so the longer you stay on the
mat just because you've been defeated
you've now become blinded as you said
and it's prevented from getting any
other opportunity or blessings in your
life so the key is getting your butt up
like literally getting up and opening
your eyes again and chasing again you're
gonna get up so you might as well do it
now rule number six make that adjustment
i'm no better than you same god that
made you made me i don't love my kids
more than you love your kids
if you may come to these adjustments man
you could change your life
you could change your family forever
it's not casual
your family tree that's so you know
something
you meet somebody wealthy their family
at one point was not wealthy
and then the one shows up
the one
one person changes a family tree forever
in my family i'm the one
and it was because i wanted it or i
hoped for it
right
hey
i fought for it
i fight for the interest give me the
info tell me what to tweak
i like that evangelist thing man that
stuff about influence is awesome i
thought he was smarter than me turns out
he's dumber than me
i want to win i want to fight for my
family i want my mom and dad proud of me
i want my kids proud of me
i want me proud of me i want to look in
the mirror and be happy with the man i
look back at rule number seven start
with the end in mind dreams compound
you'll start with certain dreams that
you think is the first dream you've got
and when you achieve that it's like a
muscle it gets bigger and you begin to
become almost like a dream maker
you almost become a dream maker where
you begin to achieve one dream and then
it also it becomes this belief you have
this faith you have that other dreams
can happen you wake up one day and
you've achieved dreams and visions and
memories in your life that you never
even initially even compelled never even
thought were possible
and now you never even conceived of them
and now you're doing things you're
living in such a way that you couldn't
have even dreamed in the beginning but
the reason you got to the ultimate dream
the bigger the dream is you could dream
dream
is because in the beginning you created
an end in mind you had a vision you had
a dream that was big enough to magnetize
people and it was big enough to get you
to stick through all the adversity
because there is adversity there's
difficult times in anything
but it's your ability to see past it to
the to the end in mind to the pot at the
end of the rainbow after the storm to
see that that gets you through the
storms rule number eight stop comparing
yourself that's the biggest thing people
do they're so obsessed with other people
that it kills them they think about what
are they thinking about me what are they
going to think about me what are they
saying and then they measure themselves
against other people too and i don't
think i mean i've been around you you're
you're a powerhouse but neither one of
us are
yeah i think you're talking about
einstein at the break neither one of us
have a super crazy off the charts iq
yeah right i sure know you don't so i
got to talk to you for enough i know for
sure you've done that a couple of times
yeah
he's taking shots out it's obvious
they're watching they know they've seen
you yeah
no but the fact of the matter is you
didn't get where you are no but you
didn't get you didn't get where you are
because of some gift i can't wait to
meet your wife though man i you know no
but it's a fact both of us didn't get
there because of some unbelievable
natural giftedness we have that just
produced success right
so i don't measure myself against other
people because they've got gifts that
are different than mine rule number nine
stop delaying happiness number one
problem in the world today is people say
i'm going to delay my happiness until a
future time once i get that relationship
then i'll let myself be happy once i
have the house then i'll be happy once i
have the car then i'll be happy once i
have the promotion i'll be happy once i
have a certain amount of money then i'll
be happy the problem is you have to
bring you to all those places and people
think if i lose if i let myself enjoy my
life right now i might lose my edge the
athletes i coach think that all the time
nothing could be further from the truth
in fact if you don't enjoy the victories
as you go your brain doesn't produce any
dopamine and you actually lose the
desire to continue to perform there's a
direct correlation between celebrating
your wins and wanting to do more of them
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is have fun so
we're here this is the global express
really global express is i guess it's
the largest or one of the two largest
corporate jets that you can really
you know buyable corporate jets that are
available and so it's owned by oracle
we're going to get on here i hope the
inside's great because if it isn't
buying this thing
this thing is
massive
just to give you an idea
of how big this thing is
look at this
[Music]
unbelievable the interior is meticulous
it's got all the upgrades you would want
millions and millions of dollars in
upgrades track has probably got more
upgrades than the plane is actually
worth
and so i'm going to pull the trigger on
this we're going to hopefully make a
deal right now
if you're wondering whether i think 2021
is going to be a better year i do
because uh
making a bet that i'm going to be using
this thing so anyway very very excited
about it and it's my dream dream dream
dream jet
you get to choose your life you get to
choose how you feel not other people
there's these illusions in life we
really can't control anything other than
our own thoughts our own behavior our
own patterns we can't control what other
people do say or think and it's this
illusion of control often times that we
can somehow manipulate other people or
manipulate situations that cause us to
fall into these patterns but what we do
have the power of in life is we have the
power to choose
and i say this to you because i'm
somebody just like you
i struggle with the different patterns i
have some of them serve me some of them
don't i sometimes engage in thoughts
that don't create the right emotions for
me that don't serve me i know what it's
like to be frustrated and angry and
depressed and down and lost and fearful
and worried worries a big one for me i
love to fall into the pattern of worry
when certain circumstances begin to
happen it creates a trigger and a
pattern in me and man do i love to worry
and so i give you these tools and
resources because these are things i too
struggle with i've been able to overcome
them by just being aware and choosing
and so the first thing is the power of
choice
finish this sentence for me i choose to
be blissful rather than blank
i choose to be blissful rather than
blank what would your answer be one of
the emotions i challenge you to
experience more of in life is bliss
you know we are the calibration of maybe
the five emotions we experience on a
regular basis
and so if you're experiencing depression
frustration worry fear anxiety pain on a
regular basis you're gonna have one life
if you're experiencing bliss and
fulfillment and ecstasy and joy
in your life and contribution
recognition and significance if you're
experiencing love you experience those
emotions you have a totally different
life we have the power to choose which
emotions we want to experience i'm
addicted to one more and so i want your
mantra going forward to be one more what
does that look like if we're working out
that means when we're in the gym and we
say i'm gonna do five sets of ten i'm
crazy like i'm a psycho because i wanna
win i wanna be somebody i want to
separate
i want to compete
and the way i do that
isn't with my giftedness because i
wasn't born with a bunch of gifts and i
think gifts are crap i think for the
most part gifted people struggle in life
because things come easy them i like
that things haven't come easy for me in
my life i like to have natural talents
in every area and maybe you like that
about you too maybe you've looked at
yourself all your life and thought man i
don't have that natural beauty or that
natural talent or this gift for
creativity or intellect or humor i don't
have any of those things but what i got
is i will outwork you and so at the gym
one of the things i focus on they say
it's five sets of ten when i'm at ten i
go one more bam 11. if i'm running on
the treadmill and it's a 45 minute run i
never finish at 45. i always go one more
minute 46.
if i'm at the office and i'm supposed to
make 25 phone calls that day when i'm at
the end of the day i always do one more
if i've got meetings i always do one
more my mantra for three decades in
business has been one more there's this
governor on our lives
and it is a governor and it's a it's
your identity it's this internal it's
what you think you're worth
it's what you think you deserve
and the problem for good people see we
all know someone right now in our life
or we have who's not ethical who's not a
good person who's winning and you're
like i can't believe they're getting it
right why can't i i'm a good person i
treat people well i'm honest here's the
reason why by the way the unethical
person eventually karma uh you reap what
you sow comes home to roost but if
you're a good person this is so
important people understand this because
it took me a long time
a good person in any endeavor will only
take from it what they think they
deserve what they think they're worth in
other words if there was a pizza here
you're a good person you don't take all
12 pieces a good person thinks there
should be an equitable distribution
bigger so i might take seven or eight
you know and i would arm wrestle you for
it you would beat me
i don't know about that you're a moose
but but long story short what is is that
you a good person will not take more
from the table of life than they think
they're worth or they think they deserve
and so you have this governor on your
identity so what happens is our it's
like a thermostat our lives get going we
start doing really well if we're a 75
degree
and our life gets to 85 and 90 degrees
unconsciously we go we don't know we're
doing it
we start to cool life back down to get
it back to where we're comfortable the
reverse is also true when things start
to go really bad and you're broke and
you're struggling you find a way to heat
your life back up to what you think
you're worth and you deserve so the way
we alter our life is sure we got to
alter our behavior and our relationships
and our circumstances but the only way
it's permanent
is that we alter that governor that
thermostat and we start to believe we're
worth 85 degrees of life 95 degrees of
life 110 degrees of life and there's
ways we can alter that how do we alter
it a couple different ways a
one is what you just said is that you
put yourself in circumstances that are
demanding of you past what you think
your capacity is and when you succeed at
them you build a new water line you do
you throw yourself out there past where
you're comfortable and you you do an 85
degrees behavior and you knock it out of
the park and you go your brain starts to
believe it repetitiously when you start
doing that you build a new line now
you're 85 degrees that's number one the
second way though is association
if you're around people and whatever
that endeavor is if it's a sport you're
in or if it's a business or your faith
or your peace if you begin to associate
with people who live in that space at a
higher temperature than you through
association you get heated up yeah and
so if you're an athlete for example
you're a 70 degree athlete and you start
training all the time with 85 and 90
degrees your identity through osmosis
goes up if you're a person is trying to
improve their faith in their life or
their their personal peace about them
you all know this you've seen it when
you start to hang around people that are
a little bit more peaceful than you or
meditate a little bit more through that
association over time the thermostat
changes in that area and so it's both
behaving in certain way and then your
associations
i believe that let's talk first of all
about getting laser focused and i mean
this is your friend i mean it's talking
to myself too i always cover things that
make me better things that i struggle
with but i got to tell you
i think there's a different level for
you i mean i think there's a different
level for you to get obsessed crazy
laser focus i say all the time our
obsessions become our possessions
but we won't possess them if we're not
truly obsessed i bet there's been a
person in your life you've been obsessed
with if you're over 20 years old listen
to this more than likely you've had
somebody you were pretty obsessed with
haven't you that you wanted in your life
you wanted to date you wanted as a
girlfriend or a boyfriend or a
significant other how many times a day
do you think about them
how many times a day did they distract
you from what you were doing with just
the thought of them
in other words this is what i want you
to understand when you're laser obsessed
focused
your obsession distracts you from what
you're currently doing not the other way
around
you're not really obsessed with it if
you're easily distracted
from it
this is so important you right now can
test whether it's your obsession with
whether it distracts you constantly the
first thing you think of when you wake
up last thing before you go to bed when
you have a big laugh it comes up when
you cry it comes up when you're watching
tv it comes up when you're doing your
regular job but it's your side hustle it
comes up you can't stop thinking about
it it distracts you from the rest of
your life
that's what an obsession does when it's
not really your obsession the rest of
your life distracts you from it
and so the it in your life is so
important but there's all these things
that distract us today i'm gonna give
you a recommendation turn your damn tv
off turn the radio off most of the time
turn your phone off a lot too i had a
really good friend of mine i went to
lunch and he said i don't know who this
guy is here
in front of me and he goes let me ask
you a question honestly
right now what are you grateful for and
at the lunch i said
jack nothing brother there's nothing
good in my life right now
and i'm not exaggerating this to you
when i tell you this and this is a
factual story as i'm mouthing these
words two people walked in with an older
man both of them clearly were fighting
cancer somehow both had lost their hair
one of the ladies had a bonnet on and
they were barely moving in both walked
by our table and gave me the most warm
greeting the warmest smile as a stranger
and he goes that's pretty freaking
pathetic you can't find anything in your
life to be grateful for right now and on
the drive home i'm not kidding you i
started to stack gratitude i started to
take inventory because if you can find
things to be grateful for in that space
man is your life going to be rich when
there really are external things to be
grateful for so my first mechanism out
of that space was honestly to stack the
things i was grateful for and i started
reinforcing it over and over and over
again
and what happens is there's this
reticular activating system in our
brains right and all of a sudden because
that's the messaging i was giving myself
all of a sudden all these things start
to come into my awareness that i'm
grateful for i start to magnetize to
myself some people that i needed to find
into my life and that was the next layer
i started to see things to be grateful
for my health my fitness people who
loved me and what it is it changed my
state when i stacked gratitude i changed
what i did in the morning and i changed
what i did in the evening and so somehow
by grabbing control of my morning and by
grabbing control of my evening i got
some measure of control over the middle
of my day i was an out of control person
back in those days meaning this i woke
up worried stressed fearful and i
immediately start thinking about a bill
i had to pay something that was wrong
and i'm in a state of reaction to begin
every i'm talking within six minutes of
waking up six seconds most people listen
to this that's what they do i said i
gotta grab control of my morning and i
set up routines in my morning
maybe they served me maybe they didn't
but they were things i could deliver on
doing for myself and so not only did
that give me control over the day but i
started to stack my self-confidence too
it's not the success of people you know
that's making you unhappy it's you're
comparing your situation to the success
they're having that creates unhappiness
in your life so for those of you that
are struggling and saying you know one
of the things i suffer from is i'm just
not very happy very often i can tell you
that that presence
of unhappiness you will always link to a
comparison of some sort either in your
own life or in other people's lives and
just being aware of that fact and
stopping the comparison embracing this
moment embracing this time knowing that
you can't go back to that previous time
knowing that you can't be in somebody
else's life you're not gonna have that
other body right now and so if you're
looking to be happier i can promise you
the number one key that i would give you
is to stop the comparison game you'd say
well that's not completely true i mean
what if someone passes away that makes
me unhappy there's no comparison there
let's take the most extreme example
or when someone's sick in my family
you know someone in my family's got a
really bad illness that makes me unhappy
that's not a comparison in fact it is
the fact of the matter is that when
someone gets sick in your family or
passes away what you do in your mind is
you compare it to when they were healthy
so that comparison of i wish they were
healthier again that is a comparison
between the previous situation
and the current condition if someone
passes away it's comparing the time that
you had them that's why people say if i
could just have one more moment with
them if i could just have another
conversation it's comparing it to when
you had the moment it's comparing it to
when you had the conversation and so
those are extreme examples
but if we reduce it all the way down to
anything right now in your life that you
say it brings me unhappiness there's no
joy there there's a comparison happening
that's not serving you persuasion
anything so if you want to persuade your
children if you want to persuade someone
to take a look at your faith if you want
to persuade someone in business if you
want to persuade someone to help you in
anything or help them in anything it's
real simple for me monster belief and so
you can't transfer to me that which
you're not experiencing yourself right
so you can't give me that people are
always trying to cover the magic word
the magic clothes the magic this and
there are words you should and shouldn't
use in persuasion no question about it
right there i think there are words that
are more effective than other words and
clearly to be successful in any business
you need to know what those words are in
your business but the best persuaders
the best motivators the best speakers
the best physicians
the best school teachers the best
parents
are incredible persuaders and what they
do is they come from a monster place of
conviction and belief that they can
transfer you to because people respond
to energy
much more than they do words they
respond to what they feel not what they
hear and see hear and see are real low
level influencers
energy spirit transfer of energy is what
people respond to and so i'm cognizant
all the time of getting in a state of
total belief and certainty about what it
is that i'm going to represent or
speaking if i'm speaking on stage about
a particular topic and then transferring
that energy into people and that seems
generic or hokey but it's actually what
great persuaders do in fact if you're
listening to this you think of anybody
that you know who's incredibly
persuasive they may have great words
they probably do but it's something you
feel from them right and that's the
difference between a great doctor and a
so-so doctor great doctor says here's
the prescription you're out of here
another one is it's gonna work or not i
don't know another one you leave their
feeling that you're going to be healed
feeling you're in good hands you feel
their certainty you feel their
confidence same when you hear a speaker
if you're buying real estate from
somebody but it's not just buying things
it's a great pastor in a church
a great person if you do tm who's taught
you tm it's their certainty it's the
energy you feel and so for me it's
always getting to i have to really
believe what i'm saying i have to really
feel it to transfer to left to my own
devices
right if you just left me like what i'd
like to do i hey man i i have no problem
laying around um i like sleeping i got
people think they meet people like you
know they're like they're robots they're
other life forms they're just different
than me no we build habits rituals and
disciplines that serve us okay now part
of those habits rituals and disciplines
have sort of turned me into a more
confident person there's no question
about that so my standards are mandatory
because you get your standards right so
the reason my standards are set so high
is because i don't want to leave it up
to my own devices right my standard is
one more minute on the treadmill my
standard is one more person i can reach
that day one more phone call one more
something and so for me i raise them
every single year but the way i get to
do it as i link it to my reasons
and so goals are really empty to me i
have a thing on goal setting but like my
big thing is that you show me something
with compelling emotional gigantic
reasons i'll show you someone who's
changing their standards all day long so
like give you one quick version that you
not heard before one of the reasons i'm
relatively fit is not just
peak state
my uncle in my family that died at 50
years old of a heart attack my godfather
my dad's only brother i kind of
resembled him
and i look like him a lot so on the way
back from his funeral my reticular
activators on heart attacks on the tv
screen on the airplane i'm listening to
music is the oprah winfrey show she's
going through a new heart scan
i've unplugged my headphones plugged
into the airplane one they're telling
this new scan at cedars-sinai that at
that time was new it could read the
plaques in your arteries the
calcifications without going you know
really invasively i scheduled it i went
in i had a world-class doctor who
understood reasons and leverage instead
of just prescribing when we coachable
you need to do this you need to do this
doctors do it take this pill take this
he understood leveraging reasons
what you do is you take the scan then
you go to lunch you come back i took the
scan i went to i had a burrito
i came back and i'm in the when i walk
in i sit down the doctor comes up and he
says
oh my
i can't believe these arteries are in
that young body
got my attention we walk back in we sit
down he could still go you need crest
store eat clean get out of here is that
what an average doctor does right no
wired me with huge reasons he goes let
me ask you a question
i heard your wife's pregnant do you have
i said i have a son and he says do you
want to be there when he graduates from
high school to be there for that day i
said yes sir yeah he goes your wife's
pregnant what do you have and i said a
daughter this is where you get a dad he
goes
she was six months pregnant he goes do
you um would you like to walk her down
the aisle on her wedding day are you
okay that it's some other man
i went what the [ __ ] is on this scan
right like and he goes i want to be very
clear with you if you keep going down
the road you're going there'll be some
other man with your son at graduation
high school and a stranger's walking
your daughter down the aisle it's not
even born yet on her wedding day and i
went boom and he goes but if you do
exactly what i tell you to do
you'll be there and so to this day
brother there are mornings when i wake
up not every morning i don't want to go
to the gym i go bella's wedding
bella's wedding bella's wedding so my
standards are high because of my big old
reasons
other dudes may miss the gym that day
because they're not going to miss their
daughter's wedding if they don't go but
i've convinced myself i get emotional
i've convinced myself i'll miss my
daughter's wedding so i will get my ass
out of bed at four o'clock in the
morning and i will get to that gym
because my reasons are bigger so my
standards are higher so that's what i
think
causes us to have great standards as
huge reasons this morning was very
unusual number one was the water was
unusually cold this morning uh really
cold and the waves were huge very big
waves this morning and both of those
things made me think about business and
there's an application for you that i
wanted to share with you the first one
was just getting into the water this
morning
it was freezing
and when i had to get in there to make a
decision how do i get in do i kind of
take my time where i go my feet in first
kind of get adapt and then come out get
adapted go back in up to my waist get a
little warmer then come back in up to my
neck you get the deal
but all that would do is extend the pain
all that does it's logical it makes
sense
don't go until you're ready take your
time but really all that does what does
that really do
that extends the pain
and so i didn't do that i did what the
pros do right which is what people do in
every endeavor that are champions is i
ran boom right in headlong right into
the water right you dive in oh there's a
shock
but then you get adapted so much more
quickly than you could possibly imagine
and then you're off to riding the waves
well the same is true in business the
champions and everything i don't care if
it's your fitness if it's your
your family your faith you name it the
way that you get great at something is
you dive into it and get adapted quickly
and you'll be surprised at your ability
to adapt and navigate your way through
success the average people in everything
frankly the people who lose are the ones
who constantly take their time they're
too logical they think well i can't do
this until i'm ready if i'm not ready
i'll mess it up and i don't want to get
it's too cold it's too it's too freezing
well the truth is in business that's not
how it works if you go slow you're
extending the time you're in pain and
worse yet
while the champions have already dove in
got acclimated they're out there riding
their waves making progress you're still
on the shore deciding whether you're
going to get ready to get ready
and so if you're an entrepreneur if
you're a business owner you're somebody
getting associated with my firm which is
a wonderful decision by the way but if
you're going to decide that
you've got to decide that and go and
trust the fact that you have
your instincts your background your
training your mentors the system around
you and that's true whether you're an
entrepreneur in my business or you're
one of these firms that i've spoken to
on the outside i want to encourage all
of you if you're going to get in get
into business and go you'll be amazed at
your capacity to evolve and to adapt and
to succeed your mind gravitates towards
which it is most familiar with
and so
if you're really familiar with what
you're worried about and what your
problems are and your fears are and that
becomes your dominating thinking i know
you've all heard this but here's the
reason why your mind loves what's
familiar
okay and so if you don't go touch dreams
for example just experience it for a
second for example we would go down once
every eight weeks if i did well in
business we really knocked it out we
could find a deal i had 200 bucks we'd
go to the ritz carlton or some hotel
ocean and for one day oceanfront feel
like what it felt like to valet your car
right walk in the lobby mr milette
welcome back right she'd go get a
massage i'd play a little bit of golf
and just for that day i'd touch the
dream and then maybe we'd do it again in
a month or two and again in a month just
little taste of it my mind began to
begin to become familiar with it and
more crazy i started to kind of trick
myself into thinking i belonged there
because we never end up anywhere we
don't believe we don't belong and then
we're not familiar with so there's these
things you'd like to do in your life
either visually seeing them over and
over again or repeating those images to
yourself that's powerful
but a double whammy is to not only
repeat them and see them but to go to
see
there's one thing that's a visual
stimulus in your brain that makes you
want to do something the triple whammies
if you could see it touch it feel it and
smell it if you allow all your senses to
experience something it becomes far more
familiar to your brain and so i'm a
massive
massive advocate of touching a dream in
any form you can get it the best of
which is actually going and experiencing
it short term
begin to believe you belong there you're
a little bit better and so i you will
not probably produce many things in your
life that you've not visited either
mentally or literally thousands of times
and so if you want to end up somewhere
you better be visiting them those could
be dreams visions but the most important
thing is if you could actually more
powerful if you go touch them short term
massive difference drive by the
neighborhood see the cars if you want to
spend your life in service for your
church or your community take a day out
every month and actually do it know what
it feels like for an afternoon to feed
the homeless or to do and you begin to
love it and feel it and believe you
belong there more and more chance that
you'll be able to do that full time
someday the key to self-confidence is
really simple
this is absolutely i've trained
hundreds of thousands of people i've
spoken to millions of people around the
world
i can tell you this the self-confident
people i know whether they are athletes
school teachers mechanics
parents stay-at-home moms you name it
they have a pattern of keeping promises
they make to themselves the groundwork
of beginning to build self-confidence is
to begin to keep the promises you make
to you and that's why it's important to
begin to even make small problems if
you're going to get up at a certain time
in the morning not only do it but then
give yourself credit say i did what i
said i was going to do if it's in your
diet or your fitness don't just eat the
healthy foods go i'm doing what i said i
was going to do you begin to build this
reputation if you're constantly being
influenced and moved by what other
people think about you it means there's
a deficiency in what you think about you
and so the key is not some you know enso
esoteric like belief system it's a
pattern of keeping the promises that you
make to you that's the groundwork of
self-confidence for sure
and it is a pattern when i meet people
that lack confidence i think let me
serve you let's begin to keep the
promises you make to you you're so
worried about there's this addiction to
other people's approval in the world
right it's the greatest the greatest
addiction today it used to be drugs
before there was alcohol there's all
these addictions sex addictions whatever
the number one addiction in the world
today is the addiction to other people's
approval and that's because we don't
approve of ourselves we or we don't feel
like a spirit a universe a god that we
believe in that approves of us and so my
confidence comes from both my faith and
in the fact that i keep promises i make
to myself that's the groundwork of all
confidence
i remember going
all the work i'd put into this all the
hopes my family and i had all the travel
ball all the everything we did all the
games all the great plays all the errors
i made the fly ball i dropped it
fullerton you know all that stuff i was
gonna get drafted then i did all that
stuff right the guys i played with
over
like a flicker man like a flicker that
crap was over and we're on that bus ride
back and i remember thinking
man i should have tried harder
i should have played harder
i should have given this more
you know the stuff guys do man you're
running sprints there's two dudes who
run every sprint full speed and then
there's the dudes who run 80 six of them
you know exactly what i'm talking about
right he's kind of cool you know it
doesn't matter i'm not the fastest guy
so no one will know when i don't win the
sprints
you know those guys you know exactly
what i'm talking about right there's a
guy kind of doesn't really catch the
ball on his throwing side in the
outfield when his warrior catches it
over he does everything wrong throws it
back that's the thing that costs the guy
getting thrown out at third and you lose
by a run because you just practice like
that the guy in the bullpen is kind of
like not really focused he's just kind
of getting loose right instead of just
laser focused on everything he's doing
all the time
right you don't want to leave here you
don't want it to end whether it ends in
the big leagues it ends in the minor
leagues it ends here or you never even
get on the field this year
okay having wondered whether you gave it
all you got because it's going to
transfer into the man you become when
you leave here and most importantly it's
going to be your identity when you get
tired when you get fatigued when you get
down when you're in a slump it's your
habits rituals routines and your
standards that carry you through if you
don't have good habits you don't have
good rituals you don't have good
routines always in your life you will
fall down in bad times and slumps and
fatigue and stress well i love that how
sometimes the things that we think are
the biggest inconvenience end up being
the best blessings absolutely man almost
every single time in fact i posted a
speech today
that i gave i got invited back to speak
to my college alma mater's baseball team
i played college baseball at university
of pacific and um i went back there and
spoke to the guys and there's a part in
the talk where i tell them that i was so
introverted my senior year i wasn't
going to graduate i had to take two
electives i was going to graduate and i
got i had previously dropped out of a
sign language class sign language
because i had to get up in front of the
class and sign it was i didn't have to
even speak i just wouldn't walk up there
move my fingers around and i dropped the
class and so it put me where i wasn't
going to graduate
and so the only class i could take to
graduate was drama and public speaking
and i had to take them both and in the
public speaking class i found a
giftedness of mine right and so what
you're saying is completely true i talk
about in this speech typically on the
other side of your greatest fear
of your greatest insecurity
is your greatest blessing everyone goes
well get out of your comfort zone you'll
find this no no what you're afraid of
and what you're insecure about on the
other side of that is typically one of
the great gifts or blessings in your
life and so that's exactly right you and
i are talking right now
because i took a public speaking class
my senior year i was stone ass afraid of
in college that's why you and i are
talking right now so you're absolutely
right you're right and how many people
have been touched now because of you
taking that class and and mutual right
and somehow that blessing that
seemingly inconsequential
scary pain in the ass for me
changed my entire life and has changed
frankly millions of other people's lives
because i went around that thing i was
afraid of it's like you don't even know
the magnitude of what it's costing you
to give into your fears and insecurities
and by the way insecurities and fears
are different things they're both really
insidious detrimental things that people
struggle with and so on the other side
of your fear
that's one thing and on the other side
of your greatest insecurity
are blessings and you have no idea the
immeasurable waves
that you're missing in your life because
you are giving in to them and cowering
to them and so it's like my life's
totally different take me a little
deeper there what what's the difference
between fear and insecurity
well fear is something that as you stare
at it there's a reaction in your body
that's actually healthy it's to protect
you we have fear in our nature because
way back in the day this is how we
survive right so fear is not an
unhealthy thing what it is is it's an
alert to you
that
hey
there's something here you need to be
more aware of
fear is an awareness emotion what most
people think is it's an avoidance
emotion fear is to make you aware right
so i had a little fear and an odd way
when my daughter was being born when my
son was being more i wasn't afraid of
having a daughter it was an awareness of
all the great things that could come
with it and my fear of what could go
wrong that day right so thank god my
daughter was born so that fear wasn't
some sign it shouldn't happen or we
shouldn't go through with it it was a
hyper awareness insecurity is a lie you
tell yourself
insecurity is completely different
insecurity is mainly things that don't
exist that you should not be aware of so
ironically people conflate these two
things and insecurity is something that
you've told yourself that is more than
likely a lie about you i'm stupid i'm
short nobody loves me no one's going to
listen to me i'm not strong enough i'm
going to blow this right what are they
going to think about me these are all
fabrications of your imagination fear is
a real thing that you should acknowledge
and see and respond to favorably
insecurities are lies
and so
most people don't make that distinction
and they actually think their
insecurities are things they should be
aware of
when in fact insecurities are things you
should not be aware of totally different
thing the people i know that are really
happy are very self-aware in fact the
best entrepreneurs i know are very
self-aware they're aware of their
shortcomings right they want to improve
them they want to get to the next
version of themselves all the time
and so for me self-confidence comes
because i didn't have it and i think
anytime you meet somebody like yourself
or myself who might now appear
self-confident it's because i really had
to find tools and resources because i
was so insecure and shy and introverted
so i had to find techniques and
resources to build that up in me and for
me it's very simple it's the promises
that i keep to myself if i have a habit
over and over beginning to stack one on
top of the other of keeping promises i
make to me not other people in other
words the minute you begin to get
external in your life worrying about
what other people think about you right
you've you've lost all control you and
it never fills you up and people's
admiration people's gratitude towards
you will never fill you up it's your own
it's your own inside and so for me
self-confidence comes from keeping the
promises i make to myself and the other
part of it is being aware i'm doing it
in other words most people don't give
themselves enough credit
all the time they're very aware of these
20 things and not aware of the 80 right
and that's why the dosage is so
important too you've nailed it it should
be 80 20 right because people get
addicted to this i'm not good at this
people don't like this about me i don't
feel good instead of focusing on the 80
and stacking up wow i did eat what i
said i was going to today i did get up
when i said i was going to i made the
amount of phone calls i treated people
in such a way i promised myself it's not
just doing those things it's rewarding
it's being aware of it and stacking that
up you wanted to be a professional
baseball player yeah right yep but then
you got an injury i did similar to me so
you never made it to the big leagues or
did you play minor league for the little
i did yeah and i played division one
college baseball too yeah i like every
guy like you and i talked about this
last time it's always our injuries that
ended our careers i probably it probably
put me
into a premature place where i was going
anyways i don't remember you weren't
gonna be in the bags for i wasn't i
played enough baseball with guys who
ended up in the big leagues to know my
limitations yeah so like anything in
life things happen for you not to you
that injury happened for me it certainly
didn't seem like it at the time but it
got me out of that and into something
like what we're talking about now that
completely changed my life so yeah but
yeah i want to be an athlete for sure
all my life all your life that was my
mask and then when it exactly and then
when it ended
your identity was like who am i right
yes lost
yeah like a lot we and i were just
telling this before we went on yeah you
know our professional athlete friends
were their career changes
i went into a like anybody like whatever
your dream is when the first one ends it
doesn't happen whether that be a
relationship it could be your marriage
it ends it was a dream right or a
business venture or a sport
i went into a pretty good depression
and uh how old were you at the time
21 22.
and i ended up you know it's because
people always see the after like the
house or whatever houses or whatever the
material things are
but i ended up bad man i ended up
depressed i ended up moving back at home
with my parents i was living in the city
i remember i was living in this sleeping
of the same bed i grew up in with the
same teddy bear the same posters i was
like going back in time like six years
i'm back where i was totally unemployed
and uh couldn't find work didn't have
the motivation to get up and find a job
just sort of eating out of their fridge
and laying around all day so that's
where i was many many years ago after
base poland when you realize things in
your life happen for you truly
especially in hindsight everybody knows
it in hindsight right if you look back
at any disaster tragedy most people look
back five ten years ago that happened
for me that was actually a good thing
and so i was unemployed i couldn't find
a job
and my old man my dad was the best dad
role model you could ever have in your
life hard-working man good man it's
better man than me has more integrity
than me he's the best man i've ever
known but when i was growing up my dad
had a drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently
and he was going to these meetings and
he comes home from one of his meetings
and says there's a guy at my meeting who
can get you a job it's right down the
street in san dimas you're going to be
working with kids doesn't pay anything
at six bucks an hour but you're gonna
get this damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning eight
a.m ask for tim
so i walked it i drive down there it's a
place called mckinley home for boys
little did i know that would alter
my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so i walk in there
i said i'm at my let i'm here for the
job they're like what job i'm like i
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah
i need to ask for tim they're like
we have no idea who the hell tim is
what's his last name i said i i don't i
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is that's hiring you i'm like
here's what i know he's an alcoholic
like oh
yeah we know that too
and so they bring me to the guy and he
says uh you're hired let's go like
literally shakes my hand and you're
hired and he introduces me to these
eight boys that were my boys they were
seven eight and nine years old and
basically i lived with these boys these
precious boys and we ended up adding a
few more my boys were all wards of the
court they were all molested by family
or parents were in prison
and so they had no family and so my
whole life changed all of a sudden these
became i'm this 22 year old guy these
guys become my sons wow and i did
holidays with them i did birthdays with
them i lived with them literally in a
home or like a literally
mckinley is a massive campus full of
children that have been displaced from
their homes that live in individual like
cottages like a foster care facility
massive though really yep all boys
it's in san dimas here and um wow it
just altered my life man because i i'd
been an athlete had a huge ego had that
mask i wanted to compete i wanted to win
i wanted attention i wanted recognition
first time literally in my life i went
wow i i love helping people i love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just i always say this all the time k
and i have those eyes too you have them
i think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction
they just have different eyes yeah they
just have these eyes that are these boys
all were different but they had that
same eyes they're just like
man love me believe in me you know care
about me and i had those eyes because i
grew up in an alcoholic family
and my whole life changed i just went
wow i love i actually love helping
people and being involved in people's
lives i didn't know that because
everything was you're great you're great
you know what it is when you're an
athlete right everything's about you
you're amazing free dinners free this
you're a stud
all of a sudden i was in a stud and all
of a sudden it wasn't about me it was
about these 10 boys that ended up being
10 of them and it just altered my life
man and so after that i ran into the
financial business that i ended up in
but i would have completely flunked out
of that financial business had i not
been with my boys for those years and i
was there for two years two years yeah
man like eight hours a day type of thing
or sometimes more sometimes 16 18. i i
think about i'm not kidding you i think
about my boys and my experience there
two of them are still very close with me
uh every day there's a moment where i
reflect on that it altered me completely
like what i wanted to do i always wanted
to be famous and rich and successful and
now i just wanted to serve yeah i wanted
to help little did i find out i could
get rich and famous and all that other
stuff i thought i wanted through serving
people identity is the governor on our
lives it's the invisible force that no
one understands and once they do
understand and get a hold of it their
life can change and so
not only if you don't get a hold of this
well these outward conditions of your
life keep being exactly the same but
it's you could behave differently you
could do all the work out you could be
thinking great thoughts but you are
going to get out of your life
you're going to be the most powerful
force in the world i think is to be
consistent with the concepts ideas and
worth that you hold for yourself you
will get that out of your life what you
will tolerate okay the deeper part of
that is identity and so identity is very
much like a thermostat sitting on a wall
right this is important once that
temperature is set at a certain degree
everything in the world externally can
hit it and you will find a way to get
that temperature so even in this house
let's say it's set at 80 degrees if we
opened up all the doors in cold air just
the worst things in life the blizzarder
of life came in the thermostat will kick
the heater on and it will regulate this
room back to 80 degrees the reverse is
also true it's a super hot day great
things are happening in your life it's
getting hotter and hotter and hotter if
you're at 80 degrees that internal
thermostat will find a way over a window
of time to cool your life right back
down to 80 degrees again so the key the
secret key is to be able to shift that
identity 90 100 120. so some of the ways
strategies to do that are are very
simple one is if i let's just say
financially
you're a 200 degree and i'm an 80 degree
if i'm in your proximity over and over
and over and over again you will heat my
identity up somewhere in between mine
and yours to 150 degrees same in fitness
same in everything so the more you can
layer in multiple people the stronger
and stronger that force is so that
changes our thermostat through
association it's a huge huge huge huge
thing people say you are who the five
people you hang around this is why
they adjust your thermostat that's
number one second way you can change
your identity is through doing short
bursts of something in a window of time
you've not done them before and they
change the thermostat temperature
permanently almost like a water line in
the pool so if it's a certain in the gym
certain amount in the gym or a certain
amount of phone calls in your business
or certain amount of appointments you
make a certain amount of money
oftentimes you're never the same again
you've seen this with your own net worth
i've seen it in mind there became a
point where i made a leap and a short
window i was never really the same again
i could go back a little bit but not
back where i was before so it's activity
or successes achievements in short
bursts of time and then our obviously
our self-confidence impacts identity too
and we've kind of covered that those are
three quick ways that's incredible so
walk me through your
your baseball career ends um i know that
your dad and you are now you said he's
your best friend who's my best friend
growing up
alcoholic father correct you said until
i think you were 14 or 15. that's right
and then um they're introducing you
constantly as the shy kid who plays
baseball baseball falls away and now
it's like
how do you get out from under well i'm
the son of uh you know somebody that
struggled with drugs and alcohol i'm uh
the kid who was supposed to be great at
baseball and now that's gone like how do
you get out from under the weight of
that yeah it is weight too um when i was
small mom i was also really undersized
so it's probably one reason i lift
weights i was always the every baseball
pitcher i'm the kid holding the sign in
the front right so i was small and
skinny they used to tease me eddie
spaghetti you know and i'd get bullied
at school and i never retaliated so i
had that mixed with shyness mixed with
chaos in my home which many people can
relate to and i got to tell you that the
shift for me sports was good for me
because it gave me an out that i finally
found something that i was pretty good
at
i think the biggest shift in our lives
the things that makes us the happiest is
that when somebody helps us identify our
natural giftedness
and when i was a little boy when i got a
little bit older they pointed out my
speed
so it wasn't my lack of size i was fast
i was the fast kid right i always wanted
to be fast kid and i got confidence in
baseball doing that when i got into
business i said you know you're intense
when someone points out a gift about you
that you also kind of intuitively know
to be true
they're linked to them you're intense
you're passionate you won't get out work
you're relentless i want i am those
things and when someone linked those
gifts to me winning now i believed i
could win that's the other way to change
identity is when someone can link your
giftedness to the victory you'll believe
it not like you're great that's general
that's [ __ ] but it's something you
know specific like for you right now
you wouldn't brag about there's a few
things you know you know what i am good
at these things right i've always been
good at these things it's natural for me
and when someone links that to you
winning like for you for example you're
an unbelievable interviewer you have
this general
you you don't need to be the smartest
person in the room because you probably
are most of the time so there's a
confidence no there's a confidence that
allows you to be present when you
interview me and just listen that's
different than anyone who's interviewed
me before and so that's a natural
giftedness for you which is why there's
a part of you that kind of knows i am
pretty you wouldn't say it i am pretty
good at this this is a good program and
so the way we change your identity the
way i changed mine was by getting in
touch with what some of my natural gifts
were and then using them in my career
using them in my life that shifted the
weight right off of me because the
weight was i suck i'm shy i'm small i
have a screwed up family that's the
weight right the lifting off of the
weight is these are some gifts god gave
me or the universe gave me or that at
least i know i have and i can spend my
life using these gifts now i've got hope
now my identity is changing now my life
takes a different direction one thing i
want to challenge you to be as a leader
of your business whether it's just
you're a leader of one which is you as a
salesperson or a leader of 10 as a team
or a company of 25 000 employees is you
must become evangelical about your cause
and your mission the greatest business
people have an evangelical property
about them they're evangelizing all the
time they're propagating the strengths
the benefits of their business of their
mission of their cause one of the great
evangelists of all time is steve jobs is
a great book written by a guy named guy
kawasaki many years ago called selling
the dream
and in that book he talks about the way
that steve jobs sold the dream of apple
and he literally called him an
evangelist for the cause there's a great
story in that book about steve jobs when
he was recruiting he knew he needed to
have a ceo of his company and he wanted
to have the best and at that time there
was a man named scully who was the head
of pepsi and jobs was this young kid in
his 20s trying to recruit this executive
had made millions of dollars and he
couldn't get him and he couldn't get him
and he couldn't get him and finally he
gets the voicemail back in those days
the answering machine actually of scully
and he says listen
listen man when you're tired of selling
sugar water to kids over there at pepsi
and you want to come change the world
freaking call me back and we'll do it
together boom and he hangs up right he
was evangelical the cause
sugar water and pepsi changed the world
at apple right and scully was making
millions of dollars a ceo one of the
most powerful companies in the world
looks to his wife and she says
i think he's right we aren't changing
the world and it was that one
cause-oriented evangelical phone call
from steve jobs and it exuded out of his
pores every stage speech he gave every
one-on-one every board meeting when he'd
meet with their software engineers when
he'd meet with the programmers he was
always evangelical internally and
externally and built a culture of one of
the greatest movements of all time in
the history of business let me tell you
one thing i've noticed about all the max
out performers that i've interviewed on
my program that i've known throughout my
life for the last 30 years really in
business sports entertainment politics
you name it the elite performers look at
time and use time completely differently
than the people who perform at an
average level the first thing i want to
tell you about people who win who max
out they are in a much bigger hurry than
the people who are average and i'm not
kidding you when i say this they're in a
bigger hurry to get to their destination
to get to their outcome their pace is
faster they walk faster they talk faster
and their expectation when they're going
to arrive at their destination is sooner
this may seem like a very small subtle
thing but i want you to evaluate
how big of a hurry are you in
because there's something to be said
about how close you think you are to a
goal
and how fast you will run to get to the
finish line let me give an example of
that if you and i started out right now
and we had a 26 mile marathon to run
right in our minds it was 26 miles we
were going to race each other
we would pace ourselves at a certain
speed in order to maintain that speed
because of the duration of the run so it
was a marathon we'd jog wouldn't we
pretty slowly you certainly wouldn't
sprint 26 miles and so because the
destination because the finish line is
so far away
our pace or our hurry is limited based
on how far away we think we are or when
we'll arrive there but if you and i were
to run a 100 yard dash would the pace be
the same because the finish line is so
much closer we'd run full speed from the
minute we took off wouldn't we because
of the proximity of how close the finish
line is
the people that win in life don't
necessarily have more vision than you
see it's not a lack of vision always
that means that you're going to lose
it's a lack of a type of vision which is
depth perception you think you're
further away from the outcome and so you
pace yourself like it and you jog all
the time throughout your life the people
that win may have a bigger vision but
they have accurate depth perception they
understand how close their goals are how
close their outcome is and they're
constantly in a sprint to get there
throughout their day that means
consequently they get started earlier
and they finish later they get up
earlier throughout the day they're in a
bigger hurry to get to the places they
need to be because the finish line in
their mind is so much closer i cannot
emphasize this enough to you is just the
pace and the way time shrinks for elite
performers compared to the average i'm
telling you the average performer can
say the same things read the same books
have the same schedule yet the person
who is in a bigger hurry throughout the
day ends up winning the day winning the
week winning the month winning the year
and winning the life i've been getting
asked lately about the struggles people
are going through with self-doubt not
believing in themselves negative
thoughts about themselves and i believe
the solution to self-doubt is to build
something bigger than that doubt which
is to build our self-confidence and one
thing to know about the fact that you
doubt yourself is one i struggle with it
as well one of the reasons i've had to
go learn to build all these tools for
myself is because in my life my baseball
career my academic career my business
career my speaking career
i've been riddled with self-doubt that
creeps up all the time in our lives am i
enough am i good enough you weren't born
doubting you weren't born discouraged
you weren't born thinking negative
things about yourself those were
thoughts that were placed in you
and given to you by an external source
at some time in your life it could even
be our parents don't do that be quiet
sit down be a good boy be a good girl
maybe it was criticism you received as a
as a little one that you may not even
remember to this day the process of
building self-confidence is actually
very easy believe it or not
self-confidence is self-trust
self-confidence is building a reputation
with yourself that you keep your word to
you that you keep the promises you make
to you when i meet somebody who has a
ton of self-confidence i don't look at
that as somebody with a big ego there's
a difference somebody with
self-confidence has a reputation with
themselves that i do the things i say
i'm going to do
that's where self-confidence comes from
when i meet someone who's not
self-confident i know this is someone
who has consistently made promises to
themselves they've not kept they've
started a diet and done it for a while
but not kept it they've made a
commitment and goals to go make a
certain amount of money in business and
they started down the road but then they
didn't deliver on it long term to get up
at a certain time in the morning and
then they don't do it and so they have a
process and a habit in their life more
often than not of not keeping the
promises they don't make to other people
they don't keep the promises they make
to themselves and so the cool thing is
self-confidence is an internal game you
do not need external accolades external
admiration in order to build
self-confidence you don't need any of
those external forces it's all done
internally you control this and you
control this by beginning today to keep
the promises you make to yourself and
you have to stack the deck in your favor
stack the game so you win it's not good
enough just to keep the promises you
make to yourself you must acknowledge it
when you do it to you to give yourself
credit to create confidence momentum is
what i call it so whether that's setting
the deck where you're going to get up a
little bit earlier you're going to make
a certain amount of phone calls you
misses a certain amount of appointments
you're going to eat a certain amount of
calories in your fitness you're going to
spend a certain amount of time with your
children or your parents and you begin
to do these things you say you're going
to do you say simple things like i'm
going to lay out my clothes the night
before i go to bed every night
before i go to sleep so when i wake up
that decision is made for me and believe
it or not the fact that you just do
something that simple that you then
deliver on begins to build confidence
you say i'm on a stretch in the morning
when i get up and you do it all of a
sudden i'm not going to check my phone
for 30 minutes all these habits i teach
when you just begin to do the things you
tell yourself you're going to do you
begin to build self-confidence which is
this reputation with yourself so ask
yourself a question right now
what is one thing right now one promise
i can make to myself that i'm going to
begin to keep starting this minute
and begin to do it it could be how often
i'm going to pick up a book and read it
but you begin to stack things you commit
to do and then you deliver on them and
you acknowledge them to yourself you're
in the process of building
self-confidence why is that so important
of all the athletes i coach when my
athletes are performing at their peak
level they're at their highest
self-confidence level in fact i love
when i watch some of the athletes i
coach get interviewed and they kind of
do this aw shucks humble routine
in their post game interviews yeah you
know just part of the team you know i
got a lot i could have done a lot better
today but inside i know these people are
incredibly self-confident people any of
you athletes listening to this you know
this the great athletes you know have
incredible amounts of self-confidence
you have to believe in you when it's a
battle when you're a hitter against a
pitcher or when you're a quarterback
against a defense or you're a defenseman
in the nhl against their best offensive
player or you're a golfer and you have
to make a nine foot putt to win a
tournament right you better have
self-confidence in fact the separator
more often than not at the highest level
in sports is not they're a better
shooter or a better putter or throw the
ball a little bit faster because
everybody throws hard in the major
leagues nowadays it seems right
that separates their self-confidence
it's true in being a parent it's true in
being a business person it's true in
every area of our life the separator at
the top levels is self-confidence you
are one decision away from changing your
life
and you have to accept that your one new
meeting one new relationship one new
contact one new action
one new decision
away from shifting your life from where
it is right now to a totally different
place so what's the decision you already
know i could go backstage now there's
something you've been hesitating on
there's a contact you need to make isn't
there there's a job you need to quit
there's a relationship you need to
engage in maybe there's a relationship
you need to leave
i don't know what it is but i know
there's a decision that you need to make
to take you to the next level just like
i know that's true for me because
decisions shape our destiny when they're
backed up by some massive ass action
okay but you can't take the action if
you don't decide everyone say yes people
avoid being desperate think of the fact
they come here tonight and they're down
they're not where they want to be
financially their relationships aren't
what they want maybe they're in a
desperate place and you might think
that's a negative thing but when you're
in a desperate place you take the best
actions desperation is a great place to
be those of you that are achieving one
of the reasons the achievement has
slowed down is you've allowed yourself
to feel less desperate
when you were broke and starting your
business or when you were brand new in
your relationship and you were desperate
to get her to love you or desperate to
get him to love you you took massive big
action how many of you are moms in the
room raise your hand you moms if you
woke up tomorrow morning and your baby
wasn't in their bed
would you be desperate right away yes or
no
big time desperation you wouldn't be
thinking about what you need to do you'd
be acting wouldn't you you'd immediately
make the decision you take massive
action you searched the house you'd go
into the street would you worry if your
makeup was on right how you looked what
people thought about you
you wouldn't would you have to have the
perfect plan to go find your baby that's
missing you wouldn't need any of that
because you were desperate
so when you remove desperation all this
[ __ ] creeps into your life where you
think you have to have the perfect plan
and look the perfect way and have the
perfect thoughts and be all zen and
perfect what you need is to be desperate
what you need is to get after it and i
want you to get desperate to make that
decision why because our obsessions
become our possessions which you obsess
about most regularly you will eventually
possess in your life the challenge for
most people sisters and brothers is that
we obsess on the things we're fearful of
what we don't have what we're worried
about and then we end up possessing
those things over and over again rather
than programming ourselves to become
obsessed with what we want what our
dreams are what we believe we deserve
when we become obsessed about those
things long term we end up possessing
those things can i get an amen for that
yes yeah most of us don't replace the
external parts of our lives because
those things happen
naturally without thought the external
results of our life in order to replace
ourselves with the next best version
requires intention requires obsession
requires desperation everyone with me on
that say yes
so it's not unnatural to change
your friends that think you're crazy to
have started your business or come to a
seminar spend money you don't have
they're the crazy ones
it's unnatural to be the same person you
are right now next year for all of you
in here the 35 year old you should be
gone next year forever and there should
be a brand new better 36 year old you 20
year olds there should be a better 21
year old next year you should constantly
be replacing yourself just like your
bones do just like your lungs do just
like your cells do it's natural to be
replacing ourselves but we're around
people who aren't so we think it's
natural not to couple ironic things
about closing and selling that you may
not have ever been told before but i'm
gonna tell you
people don't have to believe what you're
saying
is that crazy
people do not have to believe what
you're saying in fact too many of you
spend too much time trying to get people
to believe what you're saying
and you come across like a beggar
because of it
you seem desperate who's ever trained
you to get people to believe what you're
saying
doesn't get influence
there's a subtle difference that the
great ones know and you've probably
never been told this before but i know
it
and persuasion is not about getting
people to believe what you're saying you
ready
persuasion is about getting people to
believe
you believe what you're saying
that's a subtle difference brother
that's a subtle difference sister if you
start to think through i need to get
people to believe i believe this not to
get them to believe it people buy things
all the time they don't believe
people buy other things all the time
they don't understand that's okay we
want to educate we want to train but
they don't have to believe everything
you're saying if they have to do that
you're going to look like you're begging
all the time they got to believe you
believe it that's a different intention
the most certain person always
influences the set less certain person
when you're exchanging with a recruiter
a client they're either going to close
you or you're going to close them
and that's certainty certainty is
influence and you can't transfer to me
something that you're not experiencing
for real you have to really believe it
you got to really be a crusader you got
to really understand it when you really
believe something you can transfer that
certainty to me everybody with me on
that say yes this is a huge deal
it's a huge deal that you need to begin
to understand
that persuasion is they believe you
believe what you're saying i love that
most people don't take anything
seriously i love that most people aren't
coachable i love that most people don't
do what i teach or that anybody teaches
i love that that's how certain people
win half y'all haven't written a damn
word down i've said if you were in my
team i'd slap the hell out of you
i don't say that disrespectfully i say
this as a dip who had a velcro car
i don't say that talking down to you i
say wake up
you want to win you want to be a
millionaire you got to quit being so
casual
you walk slow you talk slow you
implement things slow you talk a good
game like you're going to be somebody
like you're going to make hundreds of
thousands of dollars you can't even
write a note down
you're gonna get your ass kicked in
business dude
business is a sport it's competitive you
gotta get focused
and get in a hurry
around a dude like me we will smash your
organization we come to play we're for
real
what are you
cool
i've seen all kinds of cool guys my
whole career
cool guys go broke
cool guys have little flashes in the pan
they have a good two or three years
players who implement strategies that
get focused and intense they win decades
they win multiple championships you win
for two or three years you know many
guys i've known that have made money for
two three four years that are ass broke
now
you gotta win year after year after year
to be a player in business
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want another amazing ed my let video
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and i'll see you there i love
toronto that's one of my favorite cities
on earth that's like one of the most
beautiful modern
great cities in the world so by the way
i want to tell you one thing your uh
your content is so good
that's why i mean